مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفاع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رونالدو والنصر السعودي طبعا الكل لما اجا
رونالدو على النصر كان التوقع ان النصر
راح يجيب كل الالقاب المحليه وكان متوقع
انه يكون بفارق كبير ورونالدو يسجل عدد
كبير من الاهداف الدوري السعودي ولكن ما
حصل هو غير ذلك ما يحدث الان مع النصر ان
النصر خرج من كاس الملك امام الوحده
بخساره بهدف مقابل لا شيء هو الثاني
بالدوري بعد الاتحاد بفرق ثلاث نقاط
والاتحاد قادر انه يوسع الفارق لست نقاط
لانه عنده مباراه اقل من النصر وبالتالي
هذا يعني انه رونالدو مع النصر بالموسم
الاول قد يخرج بموسم صفري السؤال اللي
بينطرح هون هو شو السبب ليش هذا الاداء
للنصر رغم وجود رونالدو والجواب بسيط انه
هذه كره قدم وليس التنس مش لعبه فرديه هي
لعبه جماعيه طب هل هذا يخص اللاعبين فقط
اكيد لا الموضوع اكبر من هيك الموضوع انه
لازم يكون في عندك فريق مستقر اداريا اول
شيء عنده استقرار اداري تاب
اداريه صحيحه بالوقت المناسب هذا الامر هو
اللي بيخدم اي فريق باي مكان بالعالم خذ
ريال مدريد كمثال
دائما قراراته ثابته عنده استقرار اداري
الفريق عايش بحاله من الثقه باستراتيجيات
الاداره وبالتالي بتتحقق النجاحات نجاح
تلوى اخر بالمقابل اذا بنطلع على انديه
اخرى عم تتغير اداراتها او اداراتها عم
تاخذ قرارات مش صحيحه باوقات غلط بتشوف
انه حتى لو كان عندك كوكبه من النجوم
واللاعبين ما راح تجيب اي لقب وهذا بالفعل
اللي صار مع النصر لانه اقاله روديجارسيا
كانت واحد الاسباب الرئيسيه لتراجع مستوى
النصر هذا الموسم نعم رودي جارسيا مع
النصر ما كان احسن شيء اكيد ما كان عم
يحقق احسن النتائج مع النصر ولكن لما تقيل
مدرب بنص الموسم تقريبا وانت عم تنافس على
لقب الدوري وعم تنافس على كاس الملك
وموجود بكل البطولات المحليه هون بتكون
عياشه الفريق بحاله فراغ ودخلته بمرحله شك
ومرحله ربما ضياع في بعض الاحيان اذا بدنا
نطلع اليوم على مثلا تجربه بايرن ميونخ مع
لما اداره بايرن ميونخ قالت
دوري ابطال اوروبا وهو مدرب كبير ولكن
شفنا انه توماس دوخيل لما اجى بنص الموسم
او بالنصف الاخير من الموسم خسر من
مانشستر سيتي ذهبيه او ذهاب وتعادل ايابو
وخرج من دوري ابطال اوروبا وشفناه عم يخسر
او عم يتعثر بمباريات متتاليه بالدوري
الالماني وعم بيخسر الصداره لصالح بروسيا
دورتموند لذلك القرارات الاداريه دائما
بتاثر على سعر الفريق وبتاثر على الموسم
بشكل عام وهذا بقودنا للنقطه الثانيه اللي
هو لازم يكون عندك استقرار فني لما بدك
تحقق انجازات لازم يكون عندك اداره فنيه
موجوده من فتره عامل استراتيجيه عامله
مشروع عارفه لوين رايحه بالفريق والفريق
متشبع او متشرب افكار هذه الاداره الفنيه
وماشي عليها على مدار الموسم وهذا امر متل
ما حكينا ما تحقق مع النصر لذلك بشكل عام
هذول نق الرئيسيتين اللي بيحددوا نجاح
الفريق في هذا الموسم او فشله النقطه
الاخرى ايضا اللي هو لازم يكون في حاله من
الانسجام بين المجموعه الانسجام بين
اللاعبين في تفاهم في وضع موجود داخل
ارضيه الملعب بصل لعيبه لمرحله في انه
فهمانين بعض عارفين بعض متعودين على بعض
وبالتالي هون بتصير تشوف منظومه ما بتصير
تشوف افراد داخل ارضيه الملعب النصر اليوم
هو مجرد افراد داخل ارضيه الملعب رونالدو
عم يحاول شوي غريب عم يحاول شوي ولكن
بالنهايه ما في منظومه داخل النصر قادره
على انها تحقق البطولات وتحقق الالقاب
وتروح بالفريق بعيد الان جماهير النصر عم
بتطالب باقاله بسلي ال معمر اللي هو رئيس
النادي هل هذا هو السبب الوحيد او هل هذه
المشكله الوحيده هذا جزء من المشكله اكيد
ولكن المشكله اكبر من ذلك المشكله بحاجه
لاستراتيجيه واضحه على مدار خمس سنوات
مقبله
بتقدر انها تقود الفريق بدوري ابطال اسيا
وبالبطولات المحليه لتح الالقاب ما يحدث
مع النصر اليوم هو درس ربما يكون لبقيه
الانديه ايضا ربما في انباء الان انه بعض
الانديه السعوديه عم تحاول تتعاقد مع ميسي
مع مودريتش مع راموس ايضا راح نرجع لنفس
النقطه ولنفس الفكره ابني مشروعك خلي عندك
استقرار فني واداري خلي عندك منظومه
ومشروع طويل الامد وبعدين دعم هذا المشروع
بلاعب لا تجد تجيب لاعب وتبني عليه مشروع
لانه بهاي العمليه بتكون حرفيا على الاقل
على المستوى الكروي عم تفشل فشل دريع اما
بالنسبه لرونالدو فرنالدو وجوده بالسعوديه
هو مش بس بهدف رياضي او كروي واعتقد انه
النصر عم يحقق الاهداف الاخرى اللي جاب
رونالدو من شانها لانه اكيد حقوق البث
يعني عدد الناس اللي عم تتابع مباريات
النصر والدوري السعودي عامه زادت بنسبه
كبيره بعد ما رونالدو اجى الاهتمام
بالدوري السعودي من قبل الصحف العالميه
والصحف بالمنطقه هون ايضا زاد بشكل كبير
بسبب وجود رونالدو زادت شعبيه النصر حول
العالم وبالسعوديه وبالمنطقه بشكل كبير
بسبب وجود رونالدو ايضا وبالتالي هاي امور
كلياتها مفيده بالنسبه للنصر ولكن يبقى
المشروع الرياضي اذا كان المشروع رياضي
فاشل او غير ناجح الى حد ما فالامور
الاخرى ايضا رح تبلش تخسرها بشكل تدريجي
لذلك اداره النصر بحاجه للتصرف بسرعه
وبحاجه للاستفاده من هذا الدرس وبناء فريق
جديد وبناء مشروع جديد للمستقبل هذا كان
كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى نلتقي
الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف خير